double dates is Danny here what any
dinner probably we'll do a little double
date dinner tonight probably if Julie
doesn't get too drunk too early
difficult to know what to pack because
there's just so many things gonna just
pack everything I mean I had six
suitcases he had ten I intended that's
just for my taxi George and Julie had
been good friends for over 15 years the
first movie together was Ocean's eleven
George doesn't party George has a lot
since all time with his prayer group so
and unfortunately their hours conflict
with the happy I haven't changed a bit
adorable we just came from George's
prayer group what has changed about you
guys since you worked together kids
marriage other than that nothing
we've got married I mean not to each
other so weird
our lives have expanded though in a
beautiful way that's why he is a married
man have you seen amals influence in him
now that you've worked together again um
only when we're at their house I see the
influence yeah yeah way in a beautiful
way that all wives have kind of
beautiful loving influence over their
husbands money monster which Clooney and
Roberts are promoting in France is their
film together who is the biggest
jokester and who breaks character the
most who gets in care look we're lucky
enough I think after all these years we
both understand we're lucky enough to
have careers and have a job and doing
something that we love so I think it's
really selfish if it's not fun for
everybody
are you still playing pranks this whole
film is a prank
something bad George is beautiful who
was thought that he turned 55 last week
55 has never looked so good
congratulation you yes hi Q isn't
everything
how did you celebrate but mostly Heidi
my really crying
cousin Apple the next one is 60 I think
60 is gonna kind of it actually doesn't
go fifty five sixty there's no there's
other years in between oh I've been
counting wrong